a monumental revelations in the last 24
hours about Michael Flynn's involvement
in the Trump administration as national
security advisor and what we now know of
as his definitive plans to eliminate
Russian sanctions for what we are look
quickly learning could have been or
clearly appear to be personally
motivated reasons what am I talking
about well a whistleblower has come
forward and we know about this because
congressman Elijah Cummings of Maryland
has gone public with what they've
learned now indicted former Trump
national security adviser Michael Flynn
told a former business associate that
sanctions against Russia would be quote
ripped up as one of the first actions of
the Trump administration and this is
huge because number one it further
confirms what we increasingly already
knew that the goal all along even before
the election of Donald Trump was to as
quickly as possible get rid of sanctions
against Russia but the even more
stunning revelation is that Michael
Flynn believed that ending the Russian
sanctions would allow a business venture
that he had been working on until June
of 2016 that involved the building of
nuclear power plants in the Middle East
to happen if indeed Russian sanctions
were ripped up which suggests a personal
financial motive for ripping up those
sanctions On January 20th inauguration
day the first day of the Donald Trump
presidency the whistleblower in question
says that Michael Flynn texted his
former business partner and said that
the nuclear power plant project was
quote good to go so this is even worse
than we thought right the plan was not
only to get rid of Russian sanctions
with no regard for American interests
with regard to those sanctions it was to
get rid of sanctions with no regard for
American interests for the enrichment of
Michael Flynn's cronies and presumably
in some way of Michael Flynn himself and
what's even more amazing is that we
appear to have pictures and video of
Michael Flynn sending these texts the
report is that Michael Flynn was texting
about this during the inauguration and
the picture that
we have up on the screen has surfaced
where you actually see in the inset in
the upper left Michael Flynn seemingly
grinning and texting during the
inauguration of Donald Trump this
whistleblower actually came forward to
Democrats back in June but a special
prosecutor Robert Muller asked that they
keep this private until his team could
investigate further and presumably
they've done that since we're hearing
about this at this time I am once again
stunned at the brazen nature of these
communications the paper trail around
the Russian meeting in Trump Tower which
we'll get to later in the show the
texting from the inauguration on his
phone by Michael Flynn it's either
stupidity or just this arrogance of
believing that they'll never be caught
or maybe some combination of the two how
is a national security adviser making
these communications by text message I
mean is he that dumb and of course the
right will say oh there's no big deal
because there's no connection between
this what Michael Flynn did and Donald
Trump and they couldn't be more wrong a
national security advisor doesn't
unilaterally promise and talk about the
ripping up of major sanctions against a
foreign power if it's not part of the
administration's plans and the fact that
Michael Flynn was so confident when he
talked about the ripping up of these
sanctions as an inevitability that tells
us it was clearly discussed within the
Trump administration and sure everyone
might have had different reasons for
wanting or planning for the elimination
of these sanctions Flynn maybe so that
this nuclear power project could go
forward but the idea that Flynn was the
only guy who knew about the Russia stuff
and he was also the only one involved in
the plan to rip up the sanctions is
completely laughable and we know it not
to be true because we know that Trump's
attorney Michael Cohen was involved in
the development of this easing of
sanctions plan and that's why this is
huge in terms of the criminal avenues
that it opens up it opens up the
possibility of conspiracy a Flynn lied
about his meetings with Russians because
he was covering up an already planned
quid pro quo of easing Russian sanctions
that is a new criminal path that could
be extended to other administration
officials and the way in which this all
went down
makes me wonder about whether bribery
was a component here as well we don't
know but definitely another angle for
robert muller here what will we know in
three months given what we're learning
every day yeah especially cuz I think
this seems like the first clear example
of a quid pro quo I mean with so much of
what's going on in the Russia story
it just seems one-sided right I mean the
Russian lawyer offered Donald Trump jr.
damaging information Hillary Clinton hmm
we don't know what they would exchange
for in return right I mean Paul Manafort
wanting to remove a pro-ukrainian piece
off the Republican platform what would
he get for that we don't really know now
we have two sides on this one we-well I
think in the Trump Tower thing we have
two sides also because it was clearly I
mean you talk about the Magnitsky stuff
that is that is indirectly I mean you're
talking about Russian sanctions but it's
not as clear as this this is a very very
clear and particularly Monteux it's for
everybody who says there's no story here
every day we're not getting closer to
wrapping it up and saying there was
nothing to see every day we're actually
getting more and more information about
how deep this went and also how is a
nuclear power plant in the Middle East
good for our national security in any
way oh yeah no it's if you believe that
the sanctions are wrong because they are
unfair or whatever you can make that
case but the idea that you're going to
ignore the national security
implications of the sanctions and say we
have some kind of country interests
national interest in nuclear power in
the Middle East that is completely
unintelligible
we'll see what we learn tomorrow send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program sponsored in
part by movement watches I have been a
wearer of movement watches now for more
than a year I love the watch and another
thing that I love about it not only the
design but also that the watch has
started just 95 bucks and that the
company is able to sell the watches
starting at just 95 dollars because they
skip the retail markup they eliminate
the middleman by selling directly to you
online and they also started sort of
like the david pakman show it was a
couple of broke college kids who wanted
cool watches but would go to a
department store and see watches with
huge price tags and they said hey I
think we can do better than this and
they've done really really well
this particular
time of year is good if you are looking
to give a gift that someone will
actually use rather than something
they'll return or put directly into the
trash as I've seen done these watches
are a really great idea for men and
women starting at 95 bucks and you can
save 15% plus get free shipping and free
returns if and this is this is the
biggest if of the entire thing you go to
MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman I'll spell it for you one
more time m v mt comm slash PA k ma n
you'll save 15% you'll get free shipping
and free returns